الاحتجاجات لن تتوقف هذه هي الكلمه
المفتاح في تقرير سري تم تسريبه من جهاز
اعلامي تابع للنظام الايراني تسريب جاء
نتيجه لاختراق لوكاله الانباء من قبل
جماعه معارضه موقع قناه ايران انترناشونال
نشرت تفاصيل مستقر من وثيقه سريه تمت
صياغتها في كواليس وكاله فارس التابعه
للحرس الثوري
وكانت الوثيقه مواجهه لقائد الحرس حسين
سلامي
الوثيقه عكست موقفا لافتا للمرشد الايراني
علي خامنئي يتوقع فيه استمرار الاحتجاجات
وعدم توقفها الوثيقه المسربه كشفت ايضا ان
النظام في ايران يعاني من الترهل من قمه
سلطاته وصولا الى قاعدته
وبالنسبه الى اليد الامنيه للنظام اظهرت
الوثيقه ان الترهل ضرب الباسيج واصفه
للجهاز بغير الفعال والعجز عن التعبئه
لوقف الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
الوثيقه حملت مفاجاه عده بينها تلاعب
النظام بالحقائق ومحاوله اظهار محدوديه
التظاهرات متلاعبا بالارقام من 600 الف
متظاهرا في التقرير السري الى مجرد 40,000
في التصريحات القضائيه
بقيت معلومه واحده وان كانت سريه لكنها
شائعه
كشفت الوثيقه ان 70% من المواطنين غير
راغبين في الخروج في مظاهرات داعمه
للحكومه
ارقام وازمه تفسر توقع المرشد باستمرار
التظاهرات وتشير ايضا الى ان الازمه هي
ازمه نظام وليس مجرد احتجاجات عابره